On est tous habitués à voir des représentations
de la structure de la Terre,
des dessins en coupe, un peu comme celui-ci.
Et à force de les voir, on se forme une image intuitive
de ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur de notre planète.
Vous savez, des continents qui dérivent en flottant
sur une espèce d'océan de magma en fusion.
Eh bien non, les continents ne flottent pas du tout
sur du magma en fusion.
En fait, ce n'est même pas liquide en-dessous.
Aujourd'hui, on va voir de quoi est vraiment fait
l'intérieur de la Terre
et comment on fait pour le savoir
sans avoir besoin d'y aller.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Bon, prenons donc cette fameuse représentation classique.
Dans cette vision schématisée,
la Terre serait constituée de trois parties.
La croûte, en surface,
en-dessous, ce qu'on appelle le manteau
et au centre, le noyau.
Alors, première précision, il existe en fait
plusieurs représentations possibles
suivant qu'on s'intéresse plutôt
aux comportements physiques des différentes parties
ou à leur composition chimique.
On va parler un peu des deux.
En surface, on a donc la croûte.
Alors, c'est une couche solide qui nous est familière puisque, évidemment, on vit dessus.
Question taille, elle fait entre 5 et 10 km d'épaisseur
au niveau des océans
et plutôt une trentaine en moyenne
au niveau des continents.
Alors, 30 km c'est à la fois peu et beaucoup.
C'est peu parce que c'est moins de 1/200
du rayon de la Terre qui fait environ 6350 km.
Donc à l'échelle de la planète,
la croûte c'est vraiment juste une mince pellicule.
Si on la rapportait à la taille d'un ballon de basket,
c'est comme si la croûte ne faisait que 0,5 mm d'épaisseur.
Mais 30 km, c'est quand même beaucoup à notre échelle.
Les mines les plus profondes du monde,
celles de Tau Tona et de Mponeng en Afrique du Sud,
ce sont des mines d'or,
ne descendent au maximum qu'à 4 km.
Et le trou le plus profond qu'on ait jamais creusé,
le forage de Kola,
près de Mourmansk dans le nord-ouest de la Russie,
n'a atteint seulement que 12 km de profondeur.
Et le trou ne fait que 23 cm de diamètre,
donc c'est un peu étroit
pour descendre et aller voir ce qui se passe en bas.
De toute façon, le projet a été abandonné
et l'entrée a même été scellée.
Tout ça pour dire que dans cet épisode,
je vais disserter sur la structure interne de la Terre
alors qu'en fait, on a à peine égratigné sa surface.
Passons maintenant à la question de la composition.
De quoi elle est faite cette croûte ?
Ça, on le voit bien autour de nous.
La croûte, c'est du caillou.
Sauf que ce qu'on appelle vulgairement un caillou,
c'est quand même un truc assez compliqué en fait.
Du point de vue de la composition chimique,
les éléments qu'on retrouve dans la croûte terrestre,
ce sont principalement de l'oxygène, du silicium,
de l'aluminium, du fer, du calcium, du sodium
du potassium, du magnésium et puis quelques autres.
Évidemment, ces éléments ne se baladent pas isolés, en fait, ils s'associent pour former des minéraux.
Par exemple, le silicium et l'oxygène
se combinent pour former du quartz, SiO2,
mais aussi des composés plus complexes
faisant intervenir d'autres éléments.
On les appelle collectivement les silicates.
On leur donne des petits noms
suivant leur composition et leur structure.
En fait, il y a tellement de possibilités
qu'on les regroupe en familles.
Il y a par exemple la famille des feldspaths
ou bien celle des micas.
Ces minéraux, on les retrouve parfois à l'état isolé
et ils forment alors de jolis cristaux
avec des belles formes géométriques plutôt sympathiques.
Mais il faut savoir que la plupart du temps,
ils sont de toute petite taille
et ils rentrent dans la composition des roches
qui sont en fait un assemblage de plusieurs minéraux.
Par exemple le granit, ce n'est pas un minéral pur,
c'est en fait une roche
composée de quartz, de feldspath et de mica
et dont l'aspect peut varier suivant la taille
et la couleur des cristaux qui le composent.
Il existe en fait plein de types de roches
qui forment la croûte terrestre
et qui varient suivant l'endroit où on se trouve,
avec en particulier des différences entre
la croûte continentale et la croûte océanique,
mais aussi des différences suivant
qu'on se trouve en surface ou en profondeur.
Par exemple, autour de nous en surface, on retrouve
souvent des roches sédimentaires, comme les calcaires,
mais en fait, en quantité, ils représentent moins de 10%
du volume total de la croûte terrestre.
Vous voyez donc que la question de la composition
de la croûte terrestre est en fait assez compliquée
et surtout dépend de si on décide
de regarder au niveau des roches,
des minéraux ou bien simplement des éléments chimiques.
Passons maintenant à ce qu'il y a sous la croûte terrestre,
cette grande région qu'on appelle le manteau.
Entre ce qu'on nous explique sur la dérive des continents
et le fait qu'au niveau des volcans on voit de la lave s'échapper,
on a bien envie de penser que le manteau
est fait de roche en fusion.
Et bien non, contrairement à ce qu'on a envie
de s'imaginer, le manteau n'est pas liquide,
il est fait de roches qui sont bien solides.
Alors pourquoi on s'imagine ça ?
Déjà peut-être à cause du fait que, effectivement
dans le manteau, il fait chaud, il fait très chaud.
Vous voyez ici un graphique qui représente la température
moyenne de la Terre en fonction de la profondeur.
Dans la mine de Tau Tona, à 4 km, il fait déjà 60°C
et dans le manteau, la température se balade
allègrement entre 1000°C et 3000°C,
or on sait qu'en laboratoire, la plupart des roches
fondent entre 800°C et 1300°C.
Donc logiquement on s'attendrait à ce que,
dans le manteau, avec la température qu'il fait,
les roches soient toutes fondues.
Oui, mais non, il y a un autre truc
à prendre en compte, c'est la pression.
De même que la température grimpe quand on
s'enfonce sous terre, la pression augmente également
et elle augmente même beaucoup.
Dans le manteau, on dépasse un million de fois
la pression atmosphérique
or, généralement, plus la pression est importante,
plus il est difficile de faire fondre un solide
parce qu'en fait sa température de fusion
augmente avec la pression.
Sur ce graphique, vous voyez une représentation de ce qu'on
pense être la courbe de fusion de la bridgmanite.
C'est un silicate de magnésium et de fer
qui est le composé principal du manteau terrestre
et quand la pression augmente, on voit que
son point de fusion augmente aussi très rapidement.
Prenons un exemple, à 1000 km de profondeur la pression et de 400 000 bars,
donc le point de fusion est autour de 3000°C,
mais à cette profondeur, il ne fait "que" 2000°C,
donc pas assez chaud pour que la roche soit fondue.
Si on s'enfonce encore un peu, à 2000 km de profondeur,
on est autour de 800 000 bars
et là, le point de fusion dépasse les 4000°C,
mais il fait "à peine" 2500°C, donc la roche est toujours solide.
En fait, où qu'on se place dans l'épaisseur du manteau,
la pression est toujours telle que le point de fusion
est bien supérieur à la température qui y règne
et donc dans le manteau, les roches sont solides, pas liquides.
Evidemment, ces chiffres de température et de pression
dans le manteau, ce sont des moyennes
et il peut toujours exister des régions,
par exemple juste sous la croûte terrestre
où il règne une pression modérée,
mais si des roches suffisamment chaudes
arrivent à remonter, elles peuvent fondre
et c'est ça qui forme les chambres magmatiques
qui alimentent les volcans.
Mais contrairement à l'image intuitive,
ces chambres ne sont pas au milieu du manteau,
elles sont généralement situées à faible profondeur,
quelques kilomètres ou quelques dizaines
de kilomètres sous la surface.
Continuons maintenant notre descente.
A environ 3000 km de profondeur, on arrive
dans une zone complètement différente:
le noyau.
Tout d'abord le noyau n'est pas fait de roche,
mais d'éléments plus lourds ou plutôt, plus denses,
en majorité du fer et un peu de nickel.
Et oui, le fer c'est dense, déjà à pression atmosphérique,
sa densité est de 8,
alors que c'est environ 3 pour la plupart des cailloux.
Dans la vie de tous les jours on a du mal
à réaliser la densité de ces métaux,
jusqu'au jour où on se retrouve à devoir porter
un bloc d'acier de la taille d'une brique de lait
et bien il pèse 8 kg.
Bref, le fer et le nickel sont lourds
et donc à la formation de la Terre, ils ont coulé
vers le centre pour former le noyau.
Mais du coup, même question, le noyau
c'est solide, ou c'est liquide
Et bien on peut faire le même raisonnement que tout à l'heure.
Voici la courbe de fusion du fer en fonction de la pression.
Vous voyez déjà que les températures de fusion sont
beaucoup plus basses que pour les constituants du manteau,
dessus je peux superposer les différentes conditions
de température et de pression
qu'on trouve au fur à mesure que l'on s'enfonce dans le noyau.
Vous voyez que sur la partie externe du noyau, la moins profonde,
la température est supérieure au point de fusion du fer,
donc à cet endroit, le fer est bien liquide.
Mais plus on s'enfonce, plus les courbes se rapprochent
et aux alentours de 5000 km de profondeur, elles se
croisent, c'est-à-dire qu'au delà de cette profondeur,
la pression est telle, que le point de fusion du fer
dépasse la température qui règne
et donc le fer est solide.
Ce petit raisonnement nous montre que le noyau
est en fait constitué de deux parties,
le noyau externe, dans lequel le fer est liquide
et le noyau interne, dans lequel la pression
est suffisante pour le maintenir solide
et c'est cette région qu'on appelle la graine.
Dans le cas du noyau externe, il n'y a donc pas de
méprise, on a bien du vrai liquide, du métal en fusion.
Alors pour être complet, il faut quand même dire
qu'il y a eu un débat chez les spécialistes
pour savoir quelle était la viscosité du fer liquide
dans ces conditions un peu extrêmes
et la réponse qui fait consensus,
c'est que le noyau externe aurait une viscosité
qui serait comprise, en gros,
entre celle de l'eau et celle de l'huile
donc c'est vraiment un vrai liquide
au sens de l'image intuitive qu'on s'en fait.
Si on y allait, on pourrait nager dedans...
enfin à 4000°C...
Ce métal en fusion qui forme le noyau externe
est même tellement liquide qu'il est agité de courants,
un peu comme dans l'océan,
mais qui ont pour origine le mouvement
de rotation de la Terre sur elle-même
et à cause d'un phénomène appelé "effet dynamo".
Ce sont ces mouvements de fer en fusion qui donnent
naissance au champ magnétique terrestre,
vous savez, celui qui oriente les boussoles.
D'ailleurs le fait que le champ magnétique trouve son origine
dans ces courants de métal a plusieurs conséquences.
Tout d'abord, comme ces courants
sont liés à la rotation de la Terre,
ça explique que les pôles magnétiques se situent
à peu près au même endroit que les pôles géographiques,
sauf que la proximité n'est pas parfaite.
Actuellement, le nord magnétique
est plutôt situé au niveau du Groenland
et d'ailleurs on sait que les pôles magnétiques se déplacent,
ils peuvent même bouger d'une dizaine de kilomètres
d'une année sur l'autre
et pire, de temps en temps, enfin à l'échelle
de quelques millions d'années quand même,
les pôles peuvent s'inverser.
C'est quelque chose qu'on sait et qu'on a pu reconstituer
grâce à l'orientation de roches qui ont des propriétés magnétiques.
Ces inversions se produisent de manière apparemment
aléatoire et la dernière a eu lieu il y a 780 000 ans
et du coup on ne sait pas quand aura lieu la prochaine.
Alors pas de panique quand même, il semble que
quand le champ magnétique s'inverse,
ça prenne quand même quelques centaines
ou quelques milliers d'années,
mais bon, il y a certains scientifiques qui pensent
que ça pourrait aller plus vite
et si jamais ça se produisait, il y aurait
quand même deux trois appareils à adapter.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Revenons maintenant à la structure de la Terre.
On l'a dit, si le noyau externe est un vrai liquide,
le manteau lui, est bien solide.
Mais du coup, comment on explique
cette idée de dérive des continents
et cette image un peu intuitive
qu'on a de croûte terrestre qui flotte.
Et bien, même s'il est solide, le manteau peut se déformer,
en quelque sorte un peu comme un liquide,
mais un liquide incroyablement visqueux,
un truc du genre, un milliard de milliards de fois
plus visqueux que du beurre de cacahuète
et du coup, les déformations du manteau
sont extrêmement lentes.
A l'interface avec la croûte terrestre,
c'est environ deux centimètres par an.
Si on regarde les choses dans leur globalité, le manteau
est animé d'un mouvement qu'on appelle de convection
et qu'on peut rapprocher de certains
mouvements de l'air ou de l'océan.
Les roches en surface sont plus froides
donc plus denses et plongent dans le manteau
et en contrepartie les roches du manteau
qui sont plus chaudes s'élèvent
et l'ensemble créé un mouvement de circulation.
Là, je le décris comme si ça se passait à cette vitesse là,
mais il faut savoir que le cycle complet
prend plutôt plusieurs dizaines de millions d'années.
Depuis le début de la vidéo, je vous raconte
plein de trucs sur la structure interne de la terre,
sur ce qui se passe à 3000 km de profondeur,
mais en même temps je vous ai dit qu'on n'avait
jamais creusé plus profond que 12 km.
Alors, comment on fait pour savoir tout ça ?
Le premier indice pour réaliser que la Terre
doit avoir une structure particulière,
c'est de regarder simplement sa densité.
On connaît son rayon, donc son volume
et on connaît sa masse,
donc on peut calculer la densité moyenne de la Terre
et on trouve environ 5,5 g par centimètre cube.
Cette valeur est plus élevée que la densité de n'importe
quelle roche, qui est généralement autour de 3.
Déjà, ça nous montre que la Terre
ne peut pas être faite juste de caillou
et la différence, on vient le voir, c'est à cause
du noyau métallique qui est beaucoup plus dense,
en fait, à cause de la pression,
sa densité est même autour de 11 ou 12.
On peut d'ailleurs faire le même raisonnement
pour la lune, calculer sa densité
et conclure qu'elle possède elle aussi un noyau métallique,
mais qui doit être beaucoup plus petit,
seulement un cinquième de son rayon.
Autre indice, ce sont les météorites
et notamment celles qu'on appelle les chondrites.
Elles proviennent de petits astéroïdes qui se sont formés
au moment de la naissance du système solaire
et donc de la Terre
et les chondrites sont des météorites
qui ne sont pas différenciées,
c'est-à-dire qu'elles n'ont pas une structure interne
avec un cœur métallique, comme la terre,
mais leur composition globale nous renseigne
sur la matière de base
qui a servi à cette époque à la formation des planètes.
Mais surtout, ce qui a révolutionné l'étude
et la compréhension de la structure interne de la terre,
c'est une invention qui était déjà connue
des Chinois depuis plusieurs siècles,
mais qui n'a pris son essor qu'au 19ème :
le sismographe.
Un sismographe, c'est un appareil qui permet
d'enregistrer les mouvements du sol
provoqués par les tremblements de terre, les séismes.
On a maintenant des sismographes
un peu partout sur la planète
et ils sont suffisamment précis pour capter les vibrations
à des distances de plusieurs milliers de kilomètres
de l'épicentre du séisme.
Mais comment ça nous renseigne
sur la structure interne de la planète ?
Tout d'abord, il faut savoir que quand la terre tremble,
elle émet des vibrations dans toutes les directions,
mais il existe deux types de vibrations du sol en profondeur:
les ondes P et les ondes S.
Le meilleur moyen de comprendre la différence,
c'est de les visualiser avec un ressort.
Une onde P, c'est ce qu'on appelle
une onde de pression et c'est ça...
La roche est comprimée à un endroit
et cette compression se propage.
Ces ondes de pression existent dans les roches, mais
aussi dans l'air, c'est comme ça que le son se propage.
Une onde S par contre, c'est ce qu'on appelle
une onde de cisaillement et c'est ça...
Ça n'est pas le même mécanisme de transmission de l'énergie
et dans les roches d'ailleurs, leur propagation
est plus lente que celle des ondes P.
Mais surtout, une grande différence
entre les ondes P et les ondes S,
c'est que les ondes P, les ondes de pression se propagent
dans les solides, dans les liquides ou dans les gaz,
alors que les ondes S, les ondes de cisaillement,
ne se propagent que dans les solides.
Quand un séisme se produit à un endroit donné,
il y a émission d'ondes un peu dans toutes les directions
et qui peuvent être détectées en d'autres points du globe
par les sismographes,
mais les ondes S ne peuvent se propager
que si elles n'ont que du solide à traverser
et elles sont stoppées, en quelque sorte,
par le liquide du noyau externe
et cela crée toute une zone, à l'opposé de l'épicentre,
dans laquelle on ne détectera pas d'onde S.
On appelle cette région la zone d'ombre.
En réalité, le schéma des trajectoires n'est pas si simple,
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué que ça.
Il faut savoir que la vitesse des ondes sismiques
dépend du milieu dans lequel elles se propagent,
c'est comme la lumière ou le son d'ailleurs,
et les ondes sismiques voyagent plus vite
dans les milieux plus denses
et donc plus elles sont profondes plus elles vont vite.
En réalité, la trajectoire des ondes est donc plutôt la suivante,
en fait elle se courbe sous l'effet des variations de densité
et du coup on obtient une zone d'ombre des ondes S
dont la taille nous renseigne à la fois
sur la densité des différentes couches
et sur l'étendue du noyau liquide qui les stoppe.
Alors, pour les ondes P, c'est plus subtil,
elles peuvent se propager dans les liquides donc
elles ne vont pas être arrêtées par le noyau externe,
mais quand elles arrivent dans cette zone où la densité
change brutalement, elles vont être déviées.
C'est d'ailleurs analogue à ce qui se passe
pour des ondes lumineuses,
quand la lumière change de milieu, qu'elle passe
de l'air à l'eau, ou de l'air au verre, ou l'inverse,
il se produit des phénomènes de déviation
des rayons qu'on appelle la réfraction.
Et bien c'est pareil pour les ondes sismiques
et notamment pour les ondes P, voilà ce qu'il se passe.
comme pour les ondes S, certaines vont être déviées
vers la surface sans avoir à traverser le noyau,
tandis que d'autres vont entrer
dans le noyau mais subir une réfraction
et cela créera aussi une zone d'ombre pour les ondes P,
mais qui sera située différemment de celle des ondes S
avec une forme un peu en anneau, comme ça.
Donc chaque fois qu'un séisme se produit, on peut apprendre
une foule de choses sur la structure interne de la terre
en analysant les ondes P et S qui sont captées par
les différents sismographes situés à la surface de la planète
et c'est parfois assez subtil.
Par exemple, je vous ai parlé de la graine tout à l'heure,
vous savez la partie solide du noyau métallique
et bien il a fallu attendre 1936 et des observations
sismiques faites par Inge Lehmann
pour découvrir qu'il y avait quelque chose
de nouveau à cet endroit là
et des mesures plus précises dans les années 70
pour confirmer qu'il s'agissait bien d'une graine solide.
Donc finalement, ça ne fait pas si longtemps que ça
qu'on connaît bien la structure interne de la terre
et d'ailleurs, pour compléter ces observations sismiques,
il faut savoir qu'il a fallu aussi pas mal d'expériences
qui ont été faites plutôt en laboratoire
sur les différents matériaux, les roches
et les métaux, qui composent la structure.
Par exemple, il a fallu réaliser en laboratoire
des mesures de densité et de fusion
sous très haute pression et sous très haute température
et aussi des simulations numériques
qui ont permis de comprendre
comment la matière s’agençait
dans des conditions aussi extrêmes.
D'ailleurs je trouve ça assez remarquable de voir que
si on arrive à en savoir autant sur la structure de la Terre,
c'est à la fois par la combinaison d'observations
sismiques à l'échelle de la planète
et d'expériences extrêmes en laboratoire
sur des échantillons minuscules.
C'est un bel exemple de sciences
ou le très grand rejoint le très petit.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo,
si elle vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à la partager
pour faire connaître à tout le monde le fait que, non,
le manteau n'est pas liquide.
Vous pouvez aussi mettre des pouces bleus, la cloche, tout ça...
Pour les actus de la chaîne,
ça se passe sur Facebook et sur Twitter
et ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent nous soutenir sur tipeee.
Merci à bientôt !